I want to start out with it with a story
this is a story about a sergeant in the
army
Edward Montoya and he was in Iraq
stationed in Iraq it was just before
Christmas time and he was in the the
mess line getting some dessert in fact
it was cheesecake and as he's sort of
standing there grabbing his cheesecake
about to start eating there's a major
explosion a huge explosion and a
terrorist has set himself off and blown
up the mess hall sergeant Montoya dies
on her table when the noise deadens he
comes out takes a look and he's okay but
he's a medic and around him are is a
carnage of people all sorts of people
some not so badly injured I was very
badly injured and as a medic his job is
to think about Who am I going to treat
and Who am I going to really not be able
to help or who can make it on their own
at least for a little while and so he's
faced with that enormous complexity and
enormous uncertainty and what does he do
and what he does is he does what a
number of people do ranging from that
grandmotherly Janet Yellen to crickets
to Mark Zuckerberg he faces complexity
with simplicity and in particular simple
rules and art sergeant Montoya invokes
the the simple rules of medical triage
in his case Janet Yellen facing so the
complexity of the federal reserve the US
economy the global economy actually has
some relatively simple rules around
interest rates that revolve around a
number for inflation it's got to be over
two percent and a number for an
employment it's gotta be below five
before she'll raise rates mark
zuckerberg also facing some complexity
has some simple rules especially around
hiring and crickets you're probably
wondering why crickets are in the
picture well you know if you're a
cricket you've got a really short life
span and you've got a really small brain
you have to keep it simple if you're a
cricket so they're they're definitely
into definitely the simple rules what is
a simple rule simple rules are shortcut
strategies that save time and effort by
focusing your attention and simplifying
how we think so basically the simple
rules a rule of thumb let me get a
little more grand
because you might have already thought
of that this is 1.01 on simple rules
first of all simple rules are simple
that means of all things there are there
you know simple rules are two to five
rules not a lot of rules two to five
something you can remember second things
simple rules depend on the person in the
situation so the rules that you have
might not necessarily be my rules and
then thirdly simple rules relate to a
specific activity they're not platitudes
like be nice to your mother or its
customer comes first kind of platitudes
let me give you a few more specifics
simple rules are simple so the three
food rules of Michael Pollan many of you
know I've probably read Michael Pollan's
book Michael Pollan is the is the
well-known university California
Berkeley professor who wrote the botany
of desire The Omnivore's Dilemma books
like that on many refrigerators around
the world people have posted Michael
Pollan's rules for eating and his rules
are pretty simple eat real food that
only that your grandmother would
recognize so if your grandmother
wouldn't know what it is don't eat it
small portions and eat mostly plants now
if you think about within that that's
really easy to remember and yet you can
you can eat cantaloupe kale blueberries
fish and meat occasionally lots and lots
of plants but not too much so fairly
simple yet you can't yet it doesn't
really restrict you all that much second
idea simple rules depend on the person
in the situation the the skinny
middle-aged guy is Michael Pollan he has
one set of rules the other people are
Stanford football players they actually
have their own eating rules Stanford
football teams eating rules are eat
breakfast because they're students and
if you recall your student days you stay
up late get up late and often skip your
breakfast so simply breakfast is the
first rule the second rule is stay
hydrated because you're very angular
these are active young guys and they
they tend to get dehydrated and that's
not good for your body so they're
supposed to drink water and the third
rule of the Stanford football team for
eating is E
as much as you want as long as you can
pick it pluck it or kill it they think
about that and it's got some similarity
to Michael Pollan right your grandmother
would recognize anything you can pick
pluck and kill so basically an emphasis
on non processed foods but beyond that
the rules are pretty different Stanford
football players are not into portion
control they're into eating as much as
you want Stanford football players are
not into mostly plants they eat a lot of
protein and they need to eat a lot of
protein there they're growing they're
growing people with who need to build
muscle so the point is simple rules
depend on the situation they depend on
the person given that we're sitting here
in the business school let me give you a
couple of more business example this is
a comparison between IndieGoGo and
Kickstarter the two crowdfunding
platforms IndieGoGo has a set of rules
around which which kinds of projects can
be on kicks on IndieGoGo the rule is
pretty simple if anything goes as long
as it's legal so you can fund your root
canal you can fund through your trip to
Europe you confront your business your
movie your Jamaican bobsled team
whatever you like or you least attempt
to fund it on IndieGoGo as long as it's
legal
by contrast Kickstarter has many more
rules in particular Kickstarter has some
rules around that you have to fit in a
certain project categories typically
around the our totally do have some
business categories but you have to fit
into about 13 categories and Kickstarter
over the years has kicked out about 25%
of the projects that are submitted to it
and it's also curated by real people who
are looking for the the merit of the
project so what's the point here the
point here is different the same
activity crowd picking crowdfunding
projects different rules why the
different rules I think partly it's it's
probably reflects the found the
background of the founders IndieGoGo is
founded by barrier people in fact
actually Berkeley Berkeley people and
it's it's a it's an egalitarian
philosophy essentially the idea is who
are we to tell who can be on the
Internet the Internet's for everybody
and we're not going to we're not going
to be gatekeepers
everybody deserves the opportunity to
grab a rich uncle off the internet
in contrast Kickstarter is coming out of
a background of the Arts in fact one of
the founders explicitly was thinking
about Kickstarter as a way to publicly
fund the arts the arts are is a curation
model and they were simply picking up on
the curation model of the arts so same
process different roles different people
finally simple rules refer to a specific
activity that you do repeatedly so for
example choosing foods you choose foods
every day specific activity if your
Kickstarter IndieGoGo you pick projects
every day so these are repeated things
that you do every day focused activities
what are they not what are they're not
is for example they're no they're not
they're not simple rules for getting for
who to chew to marry one assumes that
you know you only marry once or twice or
maybe three times but it's not it's not
a repeated activity so there's no simple
rules for eating
there's also also as I said before
simple rules are not about some massive
opportunity or platitude so for example
there aren't simple rules for curing
world hunger that's too complex a
product project so it's focused on
particular activities that you do often
okay that's the that's the beginning of
the story simple rules 1.0 some rules
2.0 is tell you a little about types of
rules it turns out that there are
different kinds of rules and that's
relevant for a couple of reasons one is
the some rules are easier to learn than
other rules so some are easy some are
hard to learn secondly someone
ironically harder learn to rules tend to
be more high-performing lead to higher
performance so learning the harder to
learn rules is is more related to high
performance and the final reason it's
important to learn the different kinds
of rules is because having a a
repertoire of rules is also more
effective than just having one kind so
that's why we're gonna talk a little bit
about kinds of rules first first rule I
will mention you as is a boundary rule a
boundary rule people use when deciding
yes or no
for example you're a judge and you want
to decide yes or no I'm bail for for
someone who's under arrest or which
alternative do you choose among a lot of
alternatives so in those two two kinds
of situations so whatever you have
mutually exclusive alternatives or you
just have too many alternatives and
you've got to pick one give you an
example out of Google when Google was
less complex than it is now there were
some problems around trying to trying to
get product development projects done
quickly how to keep up with search
features for example and there there was
some thinking about would you how do we
actually develop products faster and
maybe we should reorganize the way we do
product development a number of other
ideas finally came up with the idea what
was really stopping them and slowing
them down was their hiring and they
decided the key was how do we how do we
hire top computer scientists faster
because in general top computer
scientists are way more productive than
not so top computer science is average
computer scientists so how do we get
those people and so they came up with a
couple of rules a couple of you know
some of it was around you know just go
to top schools and look for people with
good grades and that was sort of
something you would you would do but the
other rules were more subtle one of one
of the one of the rules was look for
people who are eccentric people who've
ridden unicycles or gone to the
Himalayas for six months or been a
stay-at-home dad or something that was
out of the norm although maybe
stay-at-home dads getting more and more
more popular but in general it was it
was something people had done something
you'd never seen before and the idea
behind that was they'd found that people
who were unusual were also more creative
and that's the kind of person they
wanted the second rule was a favor of
favor people who've been referred to
them by other Googlers so Googlers
Googlers referring future Googlers and
their the idea was that a Googler knows
what a good Googler is and by the way
they also want to work with good
Googlers they'll be a good source and
then the third rule was if you see any
inaccuracy in the resume or that come
during the process don't hire that
person we want high integrity people any
fudging any inaccuracies on your resume
and you're out within that then you
could hire who you wanted but it cut
down the number of people that they were
focusing on and they started to focus on
the people they really wanted another
example of that is is a company that we
did some work with called frontier
dental they had an innovative products
around dentistry around inlays crowns
that sort of thing and their problem was
they were calling they felt they had a
great product the industry media thought
they had a great product but it wasn't
selling and they were going to dentists
and maybe they'd call 100 dentists in
two or three would talk to them and
maybe they one of them might buy it so
they were spending a lot of spinning
their wheels a lot of times trying to
sell the product what did they do they
went back and started looking at who
would actually bought their product and
was using it they also thought about
what their ideal dentist was and then
came up with some rules
the initial rules weren't very good they
were things like the ideal dentist is
between 35 and 50 well it turns out it's
really hard to tell how old somebody is
so what they ended up doing was going to
really something very simple we'll call
on dentists with innovative websites
because that's a signal that that
dentist has money and that that dentist
is forward-looking so they looked at how
innovated the website was second thing
they looked at was credit scores if the
dentist has more than two dings on the
credit report in the past year
don't go there either so they want to
innovate dentists who pay their bills
final examples just in boundary rules
just a quick one this is the weinstein
company i don't know can you see that
very well you see it okay that's a
picture of the imitation game that you
may recognize from the movies last year
one sign company has brought you the
artist the talented mr. Ripley shocked a
lot actually back in the day Pulp
Fiction the imitation game silver
linings playbook
a number of top Hollywood movies they
are known as a movie studio that is both
creative and makes makes a bunch of
money so the Nirvana of the tech world
if you will I won't go into all the
rules but one of them I think is kind of
interesting is every
every movie has a flawed but sympathetic
main character and so in the case of
Alan Turing if you saw that movie he is
a real jerk but you do feel empathy and
you'll like him I think most of us do
same with silver linings playbook it's
about a couple people who are get
romantically involved who both have
mental illness issues and again they're
both difficult people but you care about
them so isn't that every movie you're
saying to yourself well if you saw the
gone girl or bird man there was nobody
to like in those movies so this this so
the idea here is you they're flawed but
you like them they go to another kind of
role this is a how to role guiding the
basic steps of executing a task be a
couple to comment see a couple ideas
here
what is Airbnb as I'm sure many of you
probably used Airbnb at this point you
may also know that era the Airbnb
founders stumbled around for about a
year and a half after they rented out
their apartment a room in their
apartment with an air mattress and a
bagel so they sort of stumbled around
trying to figure out what the model was
finally joined Y Combinator and ended up
going to New York trying to figure out
how to build their business one of the
early rules and what I think one of the
most important rules that they developed
was first of all to focus on hosts but
secondly hosts always should have
professional pictures taken therefore
their properties why professional
pictures what that did was it made the
properties on Airbnb look slightly
better than than those properties on
sites like home away or vacation rental
by owner or whatever the other the other
incumbents slightly better-looking
properties slightly more likely to get
the renter became a virtuous cycle of
more and more building of the of the
Airbnb host and guest sides of the
market
another simple rule that they had was
all hosts should leave local tips so
tips about the local farmers market the
subway station maybe leaves museum
passes the idea there was to
differentiate the Airbnb experience from
a hotel it's personal it's about you
it's local and that
a signal to people that it was a local
experience another how to rule is
actually coming out of Twitter this is
some of the executives at Twitter those
of you who are still still working you
probably spend way too much time in
meetings and that was what some of the
Twitter executives decided they did and
so they decided to have some rules which
kind of ironically for me anyway we're
about PowerPoint and the rules were no
PowerPoint and if you commit to going to
a meeting you have to show up so why
those two rules one is why not why no
PowerPoint well because they decide that
everybody is wasting way too much time
on making powerpoints and secondly
people talk too much when they have
powerpoints so don't waste your time
making a PowerPoint don't talk too much
just come to the meeting why there why
the rule about you can't you can't
cancel out because if you have a meeting
it has four or five people and one
person doesn't show up it sort of it
detracts from what the point of the
meeting was if it mattered that that
person wasn't there you can't really
accomplish what you've done it wanted to
do you've sort of wasted everybody
else's time so you've got to show up and
finally this is a this is the White
Stripes which is which which is a band
that had probably one of the number-one
albums of the 2000s the the white blood
cells they're not as you would imagine
from that picture they're not exactly a
real bound kind of guys but the point of
this this particular slide is to say
that many people associate rules with
lack of creativity and I think that's
actually wrong a few rules is actually
more creative than no rules at all you
need some kind of constraint to play off
and in the case of the White Stripes
what they did was they they created
their album and they did it in they did
18 songs in ten days and they did that
with among other things a few simple
rules one of the rules was no solos no
covers which means note we're not
telling anybody else's songs no blues no
guitar solos no bass other than that you
could play what you wanted to play
and so the point here is that again you
need you need some kind of constraint to
be creative just adjust and what is it
it's in fact happening people say oh
think out of the box and I think what
the real thing to say is create your own
unique box and then play than that
that's where the creativity is coming
from at least part of the creativity
okay how to and boundary rules are
pretty easy to learn
let me tell let me talk a little bit on
some harder to learn rules to learn
timing rules time you girls are harder
to learn but they matter where timing
rules deadlines rhythms sequences but
they matter because they help you get
things done they help you get things
started they help you keep momentum when
you have it giving it we all got up
early this morning one one set of rules
as timing rules around insomnia so
there's some interesting rules that
seemed to work for particularly for
elderly people and they are the simple
rules of go to bed when you're tired get
up at the same time every day two simple
rules about time go when you're tired
get up at the same time back to the
business world
this actually picks re an example from
Pixar Pixar as you may know first hit
was Toy Story and Toy Story was a movie
that took Pixar about four years to
create and after the the glow of the
success of Pixar of Toy Story we're off
the Pixar executive started saying
thinking to themselves how do we make a
real business if it takes us four years
to create a movie that seems too long
how are we gonna get top talent and so
they started thinking about what are
they gonna do about that and realize
that what they really wanted to do was
release a movie every year so they
developed a rule that says we release a
movie every year and we release it like
Thanksgiving which then hits the holiday
season so every year holiday season that
is not so easy to do if you think about
it because what they had to do is take a
four year process and what they did was
essentially chunk it into year-long
blocks so there'd be a year one year two
year three year four roll it and then
having to understand what they could get
down in the first year the second year
and the third year and head team
handled each year so you basically built
a pipeline which essentially made
moviemaking
something of a factory with a very long
time and each step by the year along the
step and so they don't necessarily
release a movie every year and
occasionally they'll have a movie in
fact it just happened this year where
they weren't happy with the quality of
the movie and so they didn't release on
time but normally they hit it
occasionally they go to say June at
least but mostly they're hitting that
Thanksgiving new release Thanksgiving
new release another example is a company
that you probably don't recognize it's a
relatively young company it's called
prim quit their business is concrete one
of their businesses is concrete you've
probably have been thinking much about
concrete lately but you may know that
that concrete and cement its derivative
are is the third leading cause of a co2
pollution in the world so it's a massive
contributor to global warming and what
the guy supreme Quist did was come up
with a new concrete and they first of
all he did that by going back to ancient
Egyptian texts the Egyptians were the
first to do concrete and realize that
what the Egyptians and later on the
Romans who were also heavy users of
concrete we're doing was they were
adding blood and horsehair to the
concrete so they started thinking well
you know blood and horse hair is not
exactly 20th century or 21st century
what are we gonna do and they they
proceeded to figure out a modern
equivalent of blood and horse hair for
their concrete what it did was to cut
the co2 pollution in half in the making
of concrete and also allowed builders to
use less concrete and that concrete was
less likely to crack so it was both less
polluting to make and you use less of it
and had to replace it less often when
you actually got it in service so they
had this really great product the
question was how to sell it they went to
Las Vegas Las Vegas trade show they had
all kinds of partners around the world
who wanted to get in on the
this this concrete how to choose this is
a small company how do we choose who do
you want to partner with they decided
they came up with a couple of simple
rules to sort it out one was don't have
geographically overlapping partners if
it's one geo it's one partner pretty
simple second thing they came up with
was a little more of subtle and that was
partner with people who have a laser
screed machine now you and I probably
don't know what a laser screed machine
is but in the concrete world people know
and it's a signal that this is a company
that's innovative and high quality and
progressive so similar to the dentists
with Google website builders with lazer
screen machine was a signal of a certain
kind of contractor the third because
this is timing rules now the third was a
timing rule and that was we're going to
get a new partnership every three months
so every three months we're going to
need a partnership three months three
months three months we're a small
company we can't onboard people faster
than that on the other hand we don't
want it to last we don't want to stretch
out too far they figured they had the
capacity for three months moreover being
on a rhythm allowed them to sink much as
a difference for Pixar allowed them to
synchronize their activities their
internal activities around engineering
sales and so forth so they know
everything months to bring on your
partner everything months it's a new
partner timing rules are fairly
difficult to learn but the hardest kind
of rules to learn are stopping rules
we've probably all been in situations
where we've bought a stock I've never
sold it so we may have rules for buying
but not selling we're in a relationship
but we don't get out we have difficulty
saying when it when to call it quits so
most of us can choose to do things many
of us have trouble getting out of things
and yet it can be that we're running out
of time and resources it can be that
more promising opportunities exist so
our friends at Prem quests not only had
the rules I just told you but they had a
stopping rule and that was if a partner
has not sold our product within three
months we end the partnership they were
too slow
they weren't that interested we made a
mistake time to move on this is a
picture of Steve Blank who is known for
the lean launchpad he teaches actually I
don't think he's teaching the mystical
but I'm an I'm of the School of
Engineering and he's
with us in the engineering school but
Steve has Steve has a couple of rules
about about starting entrepreneurial
firms some of his rules are how to rules
about how to find customers he's famous
for get out of the building
talk to hundred people do it face to
face that's the first step but he also
has the backend of when to stop when do
you decide it's time to pivot when do
you decide this products not going
anywhere
and his rules are after you've talked to
your hundred customers out of the
building face to face do customers see a
problem number one number two do
customers want to solve that problem
number two number three well customers
pay to solve that problem and number
will the end will they pay you and
number four is can we actually solve the
problem so you ask yourself those four
questions and if the answers are no for
eating one of those questions you move
on because that products not going to
make it so four simple rules does the
customers see a problem well the
customer pay to solve it will they pay
us can we do it finally a final stopping
rule this is with Mount Everest this is
as many of you have probably read the
book into thin air that talks about the
death of about eight climbers in 1996 on
Mount Everest and in that climbing
expedition the leaders of the expedition
scott scott fisher in particular had a
stopping rule and that rule was if
you're not on top by 2:00 in the
afternoon you leave you turn around no
matter where you are you turn around on
the day that these eight people died in
an avalanche they were on top at four
o'clock they didn't had they had they
followed their own stopping rule those
people would be alive today but they
didn't and-and-and-and tragedy came
about so those are some of the key rules
stopping rules being hard to learn I'm
gonna say just a couple things and then
maybe you open up to you all how to
create simple rules thought like that be
kind of an interesting thing to talk
about three steps
what's your objective what do you want
more or less of keep it specific find
the bottleneck what's really keeping you
from your objective and craft the rules
how do you actually figure out the rules
with final-final I'm finding the bottom
like probably the hardest thing to do
determine the objective will go maybe
mix it up a little bit have a little bit
of a alumni stuff here this is the
Stanford football team again what's the
objective well you've probably all
wondered how Stanford went from one in
11 to a football powerhouse in fact I
don't know about you I kind of find it a
little strange that I went to a football
powerhouse in some ways I was more
comfortable with that old you know the
old foreign six Stanford when you could
always get a seat you know but that's
not our world anymore and you're maybe
wondering how that happened one of the
big if you think about the problem the
Stanford football team has is there
aren't that many guys who are smart
enough and can always get into Stanford
and can also play Division one football
that's a very small pool of people and
our team is a relatively thin team of
talent you know just isn't that much
talent and so the stamp that it turns
out that there were a number of things
that happen one of the major ones was a
guy named Shannon Turley who is our
director of strength training he has he
has a more elaborate title now but he's
basically the strength training head of
trades strength training for the
football team the football team put a
lot of emphasis on strength training but
but unlike other programs where the goal
of strength training is to benchpress
hundreds of pounds and you know clean
jerk you know hundreds of pounds and
we're PR t shirts that said your
personal best and lifting was something
you know essentially being strong
Shannon changed the objective because as
you think about the team he changed the
objective to it's not getting guys
stronger it's keeping guys injury free
which is not only morally I think
appropriate but it also turned out to be
strategically important for Stanford
football in particular
shann under Shannon the Stanford from
basically the first couple years
stanford dropped their serious injury
rate ninety percent with it with a
strategy that was around what's our
objective our objective is to keep the
guys healthy and so they're on the field
because when your guys are not healthy
even though they might be great they're
not on the field and so thinking back
what's our real objective what's our
strategic edge was extracting you very
helpful for Stanford football and this
focus on keeping players injury free so
that's first kind of money give you an
example of objective it's thinking
harder about what it is you really want
sometimes its revenue sometimes it's
costs sometimes it's growth sometimes
its profitability and sometimes it's
something like in the case of Google and
I mentioned before hiring cop computer
scientists in the case of Stanford
football staying injury free second step
is finding the bottleneck this is being
house of cards this is the bottleneck
that that that Netflix had Netflix was
faced with a situation as you may
remember where cut the cost of content
was becoming very high so they were
highly with movie studios has figured
out the streaming game and we're
starting to charge Netflix a lot and
their margins were being squeezed and so
Netflix decided to original programming
the first of which was house of cards
and this is Kevin Spacey and Robert
Robin Penn right or right pan or right I
think it's just right now the other team
not having a simple rule for getting
married anyway the problem so what's so
what's the bottleneck it turns out that
the objective of Netflix was to a large
extent creating buzz they wanted media
buzz because how else were they gonna
stand out against for example HBO so
they thought well you know for most of
television most oh what we call
television it's great writing that's
what really makes a great show what
makes Mad Men great what made the
Sopranos great it's great writing and so
at Netflix I said well you know we have
to have great writing because otherwise
you know we just aren't you know we
can't compete
- can't win with great writing and so
they thought further what is the thing
that will really win for us what will
really make us stand out and give us
buzz and there they changed the
bottlenecks they changed and they and
they address two bottlenecks that that
most of them but all the entertainment
world on television was not doing one of
them was directing let's have a list
directors and so they hired Kevin
Fincher to be their director and then
and then Kevin Fincher proceeded to
bring in on other a-list directors Kevin
Fincher did the social network girl with
the dragon ten to the movie with Brad
Pitt about the guy whose life goes so he
starts old and becomes young Benjamin
buttons that movie so a Taylor's top
director and then he had top directors
working with him as well why that
bottleneck what what did that bottleneck
do it gave it gave house of cards a
unique cinematic quality by using top
quality movie movie directors so the
house of cards simply looked different
and that created a buzz for house of
cards it was a different looking a
different looking experience on the
small screen
the second bottleneck they attacked was
programming traditionally in the
entertainment industry one buys pilots
for a show like two or three pilots then
goes six pilots maybe and then maybe
then buys a year of shows and then
secondly releases those shows every one
a week house of cards changed that house
of cards Netflix not only did not buy
pilots
Netflix bought two years of house of
cards two years of episodes and released
as you may remember the first year all
at once so you can binge watch both
binge watching and the buying two years
worth were major breaks from what most
people had done created a lot of media
buzz around house of cards got people
watching house of cards
people started binge watching house of
cards people told their friends about
binge watching house of cards you didn't
have to wait till the next week to see
if you liked the show and so on so the
point is that they went to two simple
rules that say then continued use a-list
directors on that side but also buy in
bulk and let people binge watch release
now of course looks risky or looked
risky for the average entertainment
company in Hollywood it was not so risky
for Netflix because as the Netflix guys
say we knew you'd like house of cards
before you knew you'd like house of
cards they knew from their data on on
the streaming services Netflix
subscribers likes Kevin's Kevin Spacey
they like David Fincher and they liked
the old British house of cards they were
sure house of cards was going to win
they could take a bet I'm buying in bulk
and actually ending up paying a lower
price secondly they knew you were
already been watching even though
regular media companies didn't know it
Netflix knew that their subscribers were
already watching two three four five six
episodes of whatever at once so what's
the point here they found some unique
bottlenecks and then created rules
around those finally creating the rules
I'm not gonna say too much about that
but we could talk a little later about
it if you're like creating the rules is
fairly straightforward what companies do
and this is a this is a actually
restaurant chain in Europe and based in
Czechoslovakia and they were developing
some rules around what menus to offer in
their cafeterias what they did was what
what they would the first of all what
their market was was they were based in
Prague and their market they decided was
going to be Western European and US
companies coming to Prague and looking
to have a better food experience for
their employees
so the Cisco's the Google's the
Facebook's those kinds of companies
coming to Prague
that was their market they got some
great chefs they started you know
serving great meals and they started
losing money so everyone loved the
service but they couldn't make any money
on it so what they decided was there
their objective was making money their
bottleneck process they decided was menu
planning and then they had to figure out
their rules of menu planning prior to
that there were really no rules the
chef's just had a great time figuring
out whatever they wanted to make and did
that what they did was engage the chef's
in creating the rules so that's that the
thing you won't usually want to do is
have your employees engaged or your
family members of its family rules
engage in the process
started looking over their history what
were people what mills did people like
what peel what meals were profitable
started thinking about that came up with
some rules that basically put some
discipline on the chef's and the rules
were set the menu by Wednesday of the
fall of the prior week five meals a day
in every cafeteria three meals have to
be bestsellers two meals have to be the
same across all the cafeterias so we get
some economies of scale within that oh
and and try and locally source or at
least seasonally source because it
turned out the chef's were you know
ordering up oranges in January and they
were narrow or no oranges to be found in
frog
so those simple rules Wednesdays 5 meals
to the same three bestsellers locally
sourced released seasonally sourced
within that do what you want to do and
ending up with a a 18:1 dough they
became profitable in six months and grew
their business by over 50% in a year so
basically worked out well for them but
the keys to finding the rules were
having the people who use the rules
figure out the rules looking at their
own experience they also brought in an
outside consultant to give them just an
external point of view so it's look at
your experience bringing an outside
source and perhaps ask and ask your
employees who are involved to do it
so to summarize or maybe to end up with
Leonardo DaVinci simplicity is the
ultimate sophistication and keep it
simple so that's what I got for you and
hopefully you'll have some questions
thank you thanks
any questions this morning anybody's got
yeah could you use a mic it for there's
one nearby thank you very much for that
fabulous articulation of the simple
rules side of the equation you presented
in the beginning okay I wonder if you
could say something about what you mean
by complexity and is that an assumption
everybody else in the room might share
with you that I don't and and why it is
what's the relationship between what you
see as complexity and simple rules okay
yeah complexity means that there are too
many things going on so I think most of
us in our lives have too many remotes
too many things our kids are doing too
many things to do at work
so there's too many things to do is
complexity and actually layer it on it
which I didn't talk about but it is even
more driver is uncertainty so not only
are there many things to do and they're
interconnected and it's hard to figure
out causality but also there's an
underlying uncertainty and and so not
only is it complex but it's changing and
if you try to use a complicated solution
lots of analysis lots of information
there are two problems with that one is
it's too slow the second is that you
tend to overfit the past if you're using
a lot of information you often will be
overfitting the past and the past is not
necessarily a predictor of a future in
an uncertain world and so that so it's
so it's being driven both by the
complexity as well as the uncertainty
and so for example I'm now going to get
a little bit techie here but but if you
have a big data set and you can and you
can and you can figure out equations
that fit that data
the simplest fit of the data is the most
predictive not the most complex the and
watch because what you're trying to do
is you're trying to predict the future
is that yes that's very helpful and I
guess my follow-up would be is this why
people talk about things like resilience
within
I had how complex systems are in fact
more robust like a forest that has many
species as opposed to one it does have
to do with resilience that's right yeah
I mean the under ability to respond to
all that uncertainty right in the
underlying I don't know how many of you
follow the Santa Fe Institute and
complexity theory the underlying
scientific basis is complexity theory so
if somebody wants to talk about that
afterwards I'm I'm happy to do that
complexity theory complex adaptive
systems yeah question thanks so much for
the lecture it was very interesting I
have a very simple question okay since
we're here at Stanford what are the
simple rules that the Stanford admission
department uses the simple rules that
you know they I'm sure they have them
and I'm sure they're not telling us I I
could make a guess but I'm not sure I
want that on tape but I'm sure there are
some and unfortunately you know it turns
out we are we are turning down a lot of
great kids these days I don't know it
must be an enormous ly difficult task
because there's so many great kids we're
turning down although I do have to say
as a professor every so often I'll have
a student in class and I'll wonder how
did this he how how did he or she ever
get here
and then I had Ville I have to click
back and say what was I like when I was
oh yeah now I remember yes thank you
that question is really about this
concept of continuous improvement and
standardization yes and and of course
that the rule I see as being this sort
of plateau or the standardization before
you go through the next iteration
how does at what I mean I guess the it's
just how do you lead an organization
through a continuous improvement process
if you have rules that are established
and say the environment is constantly
changing how do you negotiate negotiate
that I think well we find in working
with companies that that you try to find
the more the world is changing the fewer
the number of rules and that's just sort
of the the the if you will the meta rule
of thumb so if the rule if the world is
slowing down and it's stable you can
have a lot of
you start approaching bureaucracy but
when the world is changing you keep the
number of rural simple so it was a
smaller number
every so often you do need to change the
rules the environments changed the
competitive situation has changed I mean
a classic a classic case that many of
you would know is his Moneyball
Moneyball the one of the key rules was
you know higher signed players who have
a high on-base percentage
great rule until the Red Sox and every
other team started doing the same thing
that rule didn't work anymore you had to
change the rule the environment changed
so you do have to be sensitive to the
number if you've got a lot of movement
and then when the competitive situation
changes reassess whether or not are
these rules making sense and for because
many of you have at some point in your
life raised teenagers it's that you you
know simple rules are like a teen and
perfect for teenagers but you have to
keep updating Oh simple rules but as the
child gets older you update the rules
yeah great thank you no go on this side
then go back to that side yeah in most
of the examples you gave it seemed that
the the simple rule was coming top down
is that a necessary precondition or did
you find it the other way as well we we
found that that bottom up was actually
pretty useful in in in a lot of the
companies where we were there working
with a small company let's say and not
that small but maybe 500 million and
under or business units of bigger
companies it was more effective to have
the individuals who are going to have to
use the rules be involved with the rules
then they understood it they had no
ownership and so it was actually more
effective to go to go bottom-up using
data from the past and I come from a
little bit more of a complex world I'm a
general counsel of a company and what we
find and in our legal department is is
that oftentimes business units overlook
exposures which can be catastrophic
now there's a very small probability of
them happening how do you integrate the
probability of catastrophic exposures
and in your rulemaking I haven't run
into that very often I would think that
one
would one would turn to perhaps someone
like you and papers operating people see
what what are our biggest exposures or
what is this catastrophic risk and
what's the one thing maybe we don't want
to do let me think it's not a
catastrophic but we have I have worked
with a company where and they were they
were doing to a lot of joint ventures
and they would always put a financial
cap on the top and we don't go we don't
we don't go an adventure that's that's
bigger than this and that was that was a
way to limit exposure as far as that
that that real tail I haven't thought
too much about that have to think about
that have you thought about it oh I know
yeah yes your friend is rolling her eyes
now I don't know yes many times and I'll
give you a classic example we recently
opened up 26 locations and the legal
department recommended putting a cap on
the on the amount of the lease exposure
you could have if you had to exit the
location yeah oh the MBA said we'll
never get a lease if we do that and of
course now some of the locations are
underperforming and there are issues
that are abound and which the legal
department and my department is having
to deal with on an everyday basis I
guess the good news is you still have a
job it was a very good simple rule to
start when do we get out of there yeah
yeah in the timing rule slide the
initial slide it means the timing rules
can be useful for getting unstuck and I
was wonder if you had examples of that
yeah it's it's the idea is that that a
lot of times we always mean to do
something and if you have a timing rule
that says well actually I'm going to
I'll use actually a personal example you
know I really should exercise more which
many of us probably have that that dream
if you actually have a time rule says
I'm going to exercise every day at 5:00
or I'm going to exercise twice a week
you put that into your head that is that
that is something you can remember that
is something that you can do it becomes
more concrete for you then
gri exercise so and so that's how it can
get you unstuck okay I'm at exercise
every day at 5:00 I'm just going to do
that
for five minutes or whatever I'm gonna
do but creating that rule and why rules
one of the reasons why simple rules work
is partly if as they're fast but partly
because they're easy to remember and
even when you're tired hungry stressed
busy you only have to remember a couple
of things sure I had a question about
the stop example that you gave for Steve
Blank that's sort of the front end of
making a decision whether you do
something but you often have to stop
projects which just aren't working right
right and as they since they're
somewhere you down the road it's
organizationally complex to do that so
it's sort of reversing bet how do you
reverse bad decisions quickly in a
timely way yeah and sort of simple rules
that you may have seen yeah I've seen a
company that was pretty successful into
going into new businesses and their
simple rule for stopping was if the
business hasn't met certain revenue
targets and they had predetermined
targets in two years we either exit the
business or this team at least exits the
business and and and what that did was a
priori everybody knew that's what the
target was and so that wasn't then at
the last minute people saying oh we
almost there almost there it ended at a
certain time maybe if I add to that some
companies have rules that it's better to
fail inside the company before you go
out and fail find that you're not
performing well this might be on a
product introduction making a decision
about stopping it there before you go
through all the full rollout of things
so it's it's even getting it back yeah
inside you know to the point of simple
rules of situational in yours in the
situation you might find yourself you
may want to stop the I mean let's say
pharmaceuticals or somebody like
Genentech I know has some rules about
but when they stop a Phase one clinical
trial I mean there are the FDA rules but
they also have their own rules about
when they stop a trial thank you okay
and if you had set them up ahead of time
it's a lot easier to then I mean it
becomes less political because
everybody's agreed ahead of time this is
the rule and we're following that isn't
it then doesn't become political around
well you know maybe it's different this
time maybe this team's different it's
it's you kind of know the rule anything
else I anybody's mine this morning
anything else okay what simple rules
could you apply to the complex problem
of humanity's unrestrained
continued burning of fossil fuels hmm I
that that is a complex problem simple
rules are about a particular activity so
simple rules could be useful for a
particular thing like perhaps automotive
gas consumption simple rule in fact I
would think this isn't this isn't
climate change but is a legal example or
a government example the glass-steagall
Act that regulated investment banks and
other kinds of banks in the 1930s is a
34 page law dodd-frank with all its
extensions is 34,000 pages a law that no
one can understand no one will ever
understand and the point is that there's
something like climate change having a
zillion rules is just going to make
lawyers rich lobbyists rich and the rest
of us confuse they're not knowing what
to do and so a relatively small number
of rules I would think would be helpful
around let's say gas consumption or
solar panels or whatever I mean you
depend on particularly what what aspect
of the challenge you were looking at but
keeping the laws I think relatively
simple so that people understood them
businesses understood them so they know
how to operate within the context of
those laws I think would be a big gain
for us all helped to begin with a single
vision perhaps transforming the world's
largest industry from 85% fossil to a
hundred percent renewables as quickly as
we prudently and profitably can do so
something simple like that
I think it's gonna be something wrong
you know I think it's hard for us to all
buy in I think maybe I'm a little less
grandiose than that anyways yeah thank
you thanks for coming
looks like we're about the end of our
time but I've got I can hang out or
should I take one more question no
simple rules are wonderful and my
question is in terms of reality yes what
what happens when the people start to
second-guess the rule or make exceptions
to the rule or kind of blink when it's
time to well then you're not forcing the
rules but also maybe if a lot of people
are blinking and not enforcing it it's
probably time to change the rules and
you see them yes yes the rule is not
working anymore people are finding too
many exceptions maybe there's something
about these rules are obsolete let's go
to something new okay thanks everybody I
appreciate it and have a great weekend